what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with dark crisis and yes the
Justice League is dead that's something
that we covered in the previous videos
that we did and so with these guys out
of the picture what we end up getting
are a couple different things the first
is the funeral for the Justice League
right which is literally being put on
and is celebrating their life now this
is one of the things to understand here
when it comes to the Justice League and
especially coming off the heels of the
Black Adam film I feel like this is
something we need to talk about so when
it comes to the different superhero
teams in DC Comics if we're really
talking about the originals we're
talking about the Justice Society of
America by going on like the modern day
depiction of the team the JSA was
basically the superhero team in DC
Comics that existed during World War II
when the members of the JSA retired the
Justice League took up the mantle of
becoming the Protectors of Earth and
they really take a lot of their homage
from the JSA so much so that when the
JSA reformed when Jeff Johns was writing
it back in the early 2000s that what you
got was in a lot of of ways the Justice
League paying their respects to the
history of the JSA and there's a lot of
like they came before us they laid the
groundwork for a lot of the things that
we do that kind of stuff but the Justice
League was massive in their own right
the JSA was a more ground Roots team
they were a more base level focusing on
Earthly threats that kind of a thing the
Justice League taking to the Stars
facing off against the world ending
giant Calamity Cosmic space-faring
threats they dealt on a much larger
stage and so that's why what you see
here in this funeral is basically every
single superhero or even super powered
being from across the world for the
passing of the Justice League and you
even have some people here who are
villains right individuals there who
basically put those grievances aside
those grudges aside to pay their
respects to the team now of course as
you would expect Nightwing is the one
who's basically giving the eulogy and
that makes sense for those of you guys
who aren't really familiar with this who
don't really know why when it comes to
DC Comics different characters play
different roles right Superman is kind
of the the grandiose right the the
superhero that in one way or another
virtually all other superheroes look up
to right all other superheroes look to
this guy as like the beacon right the
light the the thing that they can they
can try to achieve but in a more
relatable way Nightwing represents that
as well and that's why if you go and you
read DC Comics Nightwing is consistently
referred to as the best of everyone
because we're Superman's like this is
what Humanity could be in the future
Nightwing is like but this is how great
we could be right now that kind of a
thing right that kind of situation and
so that's why a lot of fans are super
super hardcore about Nightwing that's
why he's one of the more celebrated
characters in DC Comics but while this
whole eulogy and this whole funeral is
going on Deathstroke is watching now
here's the really cool thing here right
because what we end up doing we don't
really get into him immediately instead
we pick up with two weeks later and
what's Happening Here is essentially
this new kind of Justice league-esque
team right just kind of a loose band of
superheroes more or less it's facing off
against Cobra which is just kind of like
this crazy religious cult that exists
out there they do have a big history
they are important in some ways but for
this story they're not but basically
what's established is that over the
course of the last two weeks a lot of
these groups are just launching strikes
at the superhero Community consistently
all the time right like literally taking
advantage of the vacuum that's left by
the Justice League everybody's launching
these attacks against superheroes and as
a result of that they're basically
stretched thin in a lot of different
ways now there are responses from people
like Hal Jordan the Green Lantern you do
have Wally West to the flash you do have
people who step in but the other part of
this is you end up having Hal Jordan and
Wally West as well as Superman that meet
with Black Adam now remember Black Adam
is the only survivor of the conflict
with Pariah everybody else died right
everybody else was was basically
destroyed or at least whisked Away by
Pariah but they're no longer part of the
equation and so because of that Black
Adam literally says like like the
Justice League was ripped apart by
pariah's Powers right like I'm the only
person who who survived I made it back
in one piece and it was only because of
the magic that I had at my disposal but
the thing about this is they don't
really know if they can trust Black Adam
on this now one of the things to know is
that you know with the film depiction of
Black Adam it wasn't really all that
wrong and in terms of the core nature of
Black Adam that movie really depicted
him more of like waking up in the world
and then realizing things are different
but what will likely take place when it
comes to the Black Adam film the second
movie is exactly as you see Black Adam
in the comics which is a fierce
predictor of conduct and that's how he
is here but sometimes he's been a hero
sometimes he's been a villain he's best
described as an anti-hero where he
doesn't really have any allegiance to
any one particular side he just has
allegiances to himself and the people of
conduct and so that's why the Justice
League releases this superhero band is a
little uncertain about trusting him
because it's like this guy has worked
against us before and what's to say that
he didn't Ally himself with Pariah or
anything like that like what's to say
that didn't happen but at the end of the
day okay The Stance of Superman or at
least super boy right Jonathan Kent the
son of Superman is we need to find some
kind of a team we have to reform the
Justice League because the Justice
League stands for more than simply just
like a group of people who face off
against threats the Justice League
stands for something greater right it
stands for the idea of Hope for
benefiting things as to what you end up
having is basically Jonathan Kent who
goes to Wally West who goes to Hal
Jordan and is like I get that you guys
want to go find Barry Allen I get that
you guys want to deal with like the
great darkness and this evil this kind
of permeating everything I totally get
that's what you're shooting for but
here's the problem the threats here on
Earth the violence is increasing these
villains are coming out of the woodwork
we have to find some way to deal with
that and their response is that's your
job that's what you're here for right
form a new Justice League form a new
team create a new team that can
basically help combat these threats on
Earth and when those threats are
neutralized you can join us in facing
off on the bigger threat now the reality
here is this makes perfect sense right
when it comes to somebody like Hal
Jordan he's a seasoned superhero he's
been around for a long long time Wally
West while he is kind of at least
started out as a protege of Barry Allen
he's been around for so long and has
done so much he's topped here as well
their efforts are better served hunting
for Barry Allen trying to find the great
Darkness focusing on the bigger threats
that are out there Jonathan is still
relatively new to the superhero scene
he's capable right he's very very
powerful but in a lot of ways he's
untested he hasn't been through the same
sort of gauntlets that like Hal Jordan
and Barry Allen and Wally West and his
father Superman Wonder Woman any of
those guys have been through over the
course of their time and so in a lot of
ways it's kind of him coming into his
own yet again sort of stepping into his
father's shoes to a degree informing the
Justice League and so what he ends up
doing is traveling to Brazil and
visiting Yara who is a woman that's kind
of taking on the newest moniker of
Wonder Girl now wonder girl is a name
that's been used over the years in DC
Comics where it was kind of like the the
Wonder Woman equivalent of like Superboy
or something like that Yara is a girl
who is part of an Amazonian tribe based
out of the Brazilian Rainforest that
ended up taking up the mantle of Wonder
Girl in the absence of Wonder Woman and
so because of her background and her
experience that when Jonathan pitches
the idea to her of forming a new Justice
League that he's putting together a team
she's just kind of like no I'm I am not
joining that team now here's the issue
here right again John is untested but in
a lot of ways and this is one of the
things that Joshua Williamson does not
overtly hit on but it's kind of been an
on running theme for John in a lot of
ways he's just the younger unproven
Superman he's not his dad and because
he's not his dad people just don't see
him the same way and it's one of those
things where despite all of that Jon
always kind of continues to persevere he
doesn't quite give up which really is
kind of a testament to the nature of his
character because for a lot of us out
there for example like I'm the third
member of my family right of my of my
father's name so because of that when
you you have this situation like living
up to the legacy of your parents in a
lot of ways a lot of us can relate to
that and it can be a difficult thing
right maybe you have a super successful
older brother or older sister or maybe
your dad was on a whole different level
of success and it's the pressure to live
up to that right but whatever it is a
lot of us have that member of our family
that we're kind of compared to by
everybody else and so unlike a lot of us
who would look at that and almost kind
of beat ourselves over the head for not
living up to that or finding ourselves
being frustrated because people just
don't see us for who we are they see us
as we could be that person Jonathan
doesn't feel that way right Jonathan
doesn't really take it that way it is a
little disheartening that nobody wants
to join his team but it's not one of
those things of like people see me as a
poor man Superman it's not really that
way and it's kind of a cool thing
because again it goes to the nature of
his character so what he ends up doing
is traveling to the city of New York and
meeting with Jace FOX NOW Jace Fox is
kind of like one of the newest versions
of Batman that's out there right like I
mean Bruce Wayne is still a character
that exists but Jace Fox was from future
state right the it was an event that DC
did where they were trying to rework
things and so on it was it was one of
those events where they were trying to
jump off interest even though nobody
really seemed to care all that much I
didn't I stopped covering it maybe like
a few issues in I was like this story
sucks and I'll probably go back and
delete the videos because you know
whatever we're probably never gonna
finish it maybe we will I don't know I
don't have a desire to but the important
thing here is that Jace Fox is the
newest iteration of Batman and so when
you have Jonathan who shows up and is
like hey uh so like Superman needs a
Batman dude like world's finest right
like my dad Bruce Wayne you and I can
make that kind of thing happen too the
response of Jace who is similar to Bruce
Wayne in the sense that he's a little
skeptical but he's also more cynical
than Bruce Wayne was his response is
like no like I'm not doing that the last
Batman who teamed up with anybody ended
up dead go ask one of the robins but I'm
not teaming up with anybody and he
ultimately leaves and that's when you
kind of get a little bit of
disheartening to a degree but you also
end up getting people who join his side
right so for example you end up getting
getting like like well Swamp Thing says
no but you do end up getting like Harley
Quinn who seems to join his side you get
Damien Wayne who joins right killer
frost is like I mean I guess right like
uh Supergirl is kind of like I mean you
know maybe right but like these
different people kind of seem to latch
on and seem to to take on the idea and
so what you end up getting is of course
the Justice League basically reforming
now the funny thing about this is you do
have Jonathan who has a conversation
with Black Adam and black Adam's
response is like I get what you're
trying to do here Jonathan but here's
the issue you're not ready for this
right you have this picture of the
Justice League in your head which is a
romanticized ideology right but you're
not actually seeing the Justice League
for what it is and that's a fair point
to make because as people we do that all
the time right Nostalgia is a perfect
example of that just because we remember
things being a certain way doesn't mean
they were that way that's just how we
remember it right like the perfect life
when we were little kids and when it
comes to Jonathan looking at the Justice
League it's the same way so many people
out there looked at the Justice League
as like these great Heroes who did great
things and in a lot of ways they did
they were great Heroes who did great
things but there's a difference between
watching the Justice League and being in
the Justice League putting your life on
the line every single time you go out
and face some threat never knowing if
you're gonna make it back alive having
the back of that person and trusting
that person will have your back as well
fighting as a cohesive organized team
that when it came to the Justice League
as it existed the reason why it was so
capable is because one the experience
the various Heroes brought to the table
but two they had spent so long working
together right it's like being in a
marriage where you've been together for
like 50 years after a while you just
know what the other person's thinking
and when it was the Justice League it
was the exact same way because they'd
spend so much time together they were
just kind of one cohesive unit that
could almost function effortlessly what
Jonathan's doing here is he's taken the
idealized romanticized view of the
Justice League slapping a team together
and saying we can be just like them all
the while seemingly failing to realize
that everybody has their own little
quirks they have their own little unique
attributes and different things like
that and that that's going to come to
bear in terms of how the team functions
if it even really functions effectively
at all but the benefit of what what
Jonathan's doing here is this represents
the fact that he hasn't given up it
represents the fact that he hasn't quit
that at the end of the day the world
does need a Justice League and Jonathan
Kent has formed a new one so with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace